Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode du Coup de Phil'
Il y a quelques mois, je vous ai fait un Coup de Phil' un petit peu différent
Il s'agissait d'une histoire, c'était le mythe de Prométhée avec la vision de Platon
D'ailleurs la vidéo est toujours disponible, vous pouvez la voir ici
Cette fois-ci on va parler d'une autre vision, celle d'Hésiode
Un poète grec et on va parler du mythe de la boite de Pandore
Il y a hyper longtemps les hommes et les dieux vivaient ensemble dans le plus grand des calmes
Il n'y avait pas de morts, pas de maladies, pas de vieillesse, pas de faim, pas de soif
La nourriture poussait toute seule
Et il y avait pas de femmes aussi
Oui ^^
Bref, tout allait plutôt bien jusqu'au moment où Zeus accède au pouvoir suprême
En défonçant Cronos
Et là Zeus se dit que c'est pas forcément normal qu'il y ait les hommes et les dieux qui vivent ensemble
Alors que les hommes sont clairement inférieurs
Du coup, il appelle Prométhée, celui qui "pense avant". C'est un Titan
Et lui demande de s'occuper du problème
Pour donner aux hommes et aux dieux la place qui leur correspond dans l'univers
Et savoir quelle part leur donner dans l'Ordre cosmique
Prométhée sacrifie un Bœuf et va en faire deux parts
Dans la première part, il va mettre des trucs pas très comestibles
Genre des os, et il va recouvrir ça d'une mince couche de graisse assez appétissante
Et dans la seconde part, il va mettre de la bonne viande, genre la bonne pièce de chez le boucher
Et il va recouvrir ça de trucs un peu dégueux, genre des boyaux etc ....
Et donc il va faire choisir ça à Zeus
Du coup, en fait il essaie de tromper Zeus, et il est un petit peu dans le camp des hommes
Sauf que Zeus sait tout, donc c'est pas hyper malin de la part de Prométhée
J'te conseille de faire attention Zeus, tout laisse penser que j'ai un carré d'As
*Pensée* Putain j'espère qu'il va se coucher
Non mais j'suis Zeus, je sais tout ! T'as un Cinq et un Sept, j'le sais quoi
*Pensée* Là, je tente le tout pour le tout !
Ok ... Tu vas p'tetre me croire à présent .... Si je te dis tapis!
Alors je savais que t'étais con, mais alors là !
Il est con, on est d'accord ! T'es con, t'es complètement con
Alors on pourrait croire que Zeus va prendre la part où il y a la bonne viande
Mais non ! Il fait exprès et rentre dans le jeu de Prométhée
Et forcément il est pas content
Cette scène s'appelle le partage de Mékôné
Et après ça, Zeus va vouloir se venger en punissant les hommes
Alors qu'on avait quand même rien à voir là dedans !
En fait il va leur imposer le travail et l'effort, qui sont quelque chose de complètement nouveau pour eux
Par exemple, il va cacher la nourriture
Genre il va prendre du blé et le cacher en le mettant sous la terre
D'ailleurs le blé c'est pas anodin, c'est la nourriture à la base du pain
Et le pain c'est la nourriture qui caractérise les hommes en tant que tel
Parce que ni les dieux en mangent, ni les bêtes
Et Zeus ne s'arrête pas là, il fait la même chose avec le feu en le confisquant aux hommes
Sans feu, c'est difficile de faire cuire du blé pour obtenir du pain
Ou même difficile de faire cuire la viande offerte par Prométhée
Du coup, Prométhée qui se sent mal et qui veut se rattraper, va prendre une branche de fenouille
Et va aller chercher un petit bout du feu divin de Zeus pour le cacher dedans
En gros pour résumer, on a Prométhée qui est un gros rebelle
Qui se fait prendre une première fois par Zeus et qui va ensuite prendre son feu ! Le mec est chaud quoi
Chaud ... Feu ... Le feu, chaud ^^
Tu l'as eu ou pas ? Non parce que t'sais la chaleur ....
Il va ensuite discrètement donner le feu aux hommes qui vont pouvoir se chauffer et faire cuire leurs aliments
*accent Corse* Ah ben nous on était content, ça c'est sûr ! Depuis le début de l'aventure, on enchaîne les galères
On nous a supprimé le blé, ensuite le feu ! Ah ben bien sûr, ça nous a reboosté pour la suite de l'aventure, c'est sûr !
Sauf que Zeus ... bah c'est pas compliqué, il sait tout !
Du coup il découvre ce qu'a fait Prométhée et décide d'aller encore plus loin dans la punition
Il convoque Hếphaistos, le dieu du feu, et lui demande de créer un manequin de jeune fille
Basé sur une vierge avant ses noces et faite à l'image de 3 déesses. Athéna, Hestia, et Artémis
C'est Pandore, et c'est une bombe !
On lui donne la parure d'Athéna, une couronne majestueuse, la parole pour qu'elle puisse s'exprimer
Et, je cite le texte, " un coeur de chienne et un tempérament de voleuse"
Voila, sympa pour la première femme de la civilisation
Et Zeus l'offre aux hommes en disant, je cite :
" Elle sera le malheur des hommes, un malheur plein de beauté, que les hommes chériront plus que tout"
Bon cadeau empoisonné qui fait plaisir ^^
Pendant ce temps, Prométhée, celui qui réfléchit avant
Il voit le coup venir et prévient son frère, Épiméthée, celui qui réfléchit après
En lui disant : bah si jamais tu reçois un cadeau des dieux, soit méfiant !
Et là il y a Pandore qui arrive sur Terre et toc à la porte d'Épiméthée
Il la fait rentrer, il tombe amoureux d'elle et ils se marient
Merci mec ! T'avais UN job !
Alors là ! C'est la stupéfaction
Alors depuis le début, on enchaîne les épreuves, nous on s'est dit c'est un rouge qui va sortir au conseil
On nous apporte quoi ? Ça s'appelle une femme apparemment
Non ! Moi j'ai vu des bœuf, des bestioles et tout mais ça j'avais jamais vu !
Je m'y attendais pas hein
Personne s'y attendait !
Sauf que Pandore vient pas seule sur Terre, elle vient avec une jare
Qu'on a appelé après une boîte
Qui est complètement fermée. Et elle doit pas l'ouvrir
Elle doit pas l'ouvrir !
Du tout !
Donc, elle ouvre la boîte et il y a plein de petits trucs qui s'envolent et Zeus lui demande de refermer la boîte tout de suite
En fait elle vient de libérer tous les maux de la Terre
Et elle joue pas au Scrabble, c'est les maux M-A-U-X
T'sais c'est la mort, la maladie, la vieillesse, la peur, la douleur, Touche pas à mon poste, ce genre de choses
Mais il reste au fond de la boîte une seule chose
L'espoir
Parfait !
Bon, j'sais pas quoi dire ! J'suis dégoûté !
On avait l'épreuve de confort la plus simple ! Enfin, fallait juste prendre une boîte et pas l'ouvrir
Et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?! Elle l'ouvre ... Putain ! J'ai le seum moi !
j'voulais trop avoir le courrier des proches !
En plus ça fait une semaine que tout le monde est malade au camp, j'sais même pas ce que c'est !
C'est peut-être le fenouille hein
Alors ce qui est intéressant dans cette histoire c'est évidemment tout ce qu'il y a derrière
Et c'est les points qui tournent autour de Pandore. Ce qu'elle est, ce qu'elle fait et ce qu'elle représente
D'abord ce qu'elle est :
C'est une femme, la première dans le monde des hommes
Mais c'est une femme artificielle
Il y avait d'abord les hommes et ensuite il y a eu la femme
Donc sa présence sur Terre est pas aussi légitime que celle des hommes
Et en plus c'est une femme qui a été créée pour nuire aux hommes
Donc là j'avoue qu'on touche un tout petit peu au sexisme de nos amis grecs
Puisque c'est une femme qui va pervertir le monde établi
Mais c'est intéressant parce que ça donne peut-être des pistes de réflexion sur la vision de l'époque
Ensuite il y a ce qu'elle fait :
Elle libère tous les maux de la boîte, ou de la jare, sauf un : l'espoir
Sauf qu'il s'agit pas réellement de l'espoir comme on le dit aussi souvent
Du tout
Le mot utilisé dans la version initiale c'est : Elpis. Mais ça se traduit plutôt par : L'attente ou être dans l'expectative
Donc oui, si c'est une bonne chose qu'on attends, ce sera de l'espoir
Si c'est une mauvaise chose, ce sera de l'anxiété
Et il y a de gros contresens là dessus et c'est peut-être l'aspect le plus terrible de la punition de Zeus
C'est laisser l'Elpis dans la jare, c'est-à-dire le laisser aux hommes
Il n'y a pas pire punition que d'espérer ou d'attendre
Si on espère être en bonne santé, c'est qu'on ne l'est pas, qu'on est malade
Si on pétait la forme on aurait pas besoin d'espérer
Du coup, selon la philosophie grecque et aussi bouddhiste par exemple
L'espérance est négatif
Donc on se retrouve dans un monde envahis par tous les maux
Et la seule ressource qu'on a
C'est l'attente de les voir venir et l'espoir de les éviter
ça craint !
Le dernier point sur Pandore c'est la dualité qu'elle représente
Elle a une apparence attractive, divine
Et elle abrite un fond qui est mauvais, néfaste pour l'homme
Le faux est caché dans le vrai
Et ça paraît à différents moments du mythe
Par exemple quand Prométhée lui offre les os, il y a une très belle enveloppe
Ou alors, quand il va chercher le feu divin, il le cache dans du fenouille
Toutes les actions primordiales de ce récit agissent sur le même levier : distinguer l'apparence du fond
Et finalement dans ce mythe, il y a des choses qu'on retrouve dans nos vies quotidiennes
Par exemple, devoir gérer notre espérance ou notre anxiété afin de ne pas trop souffrir
Et ensuite savoir distinguer le vrai du faux malgré les apparences
D'ailleurs sur ce dernier point, ça me rappelle une notion des grecs qu'on a déjà vu ensemble, c'est : Kalos Kagathos
C'est ce qui est bon et beau
Eh bien, ce mythe va totalement à l'encontre de cette notion là
Si cette vidéo vous a permis de distinguer le vrai du faux autour du mythe de Pandore
Eh bien n'hésitez pas à passer le coup de Phil' à un ami
On se retrouve dans quelques jours pour une nouvelle vidéo
Le prochain Coup de Phil' ce sera de la philo pure, donc une notion de philo pure et pas un mythe
D'ici là je vous envoie du love et de la peace :)
Merci pour tous vos retours sur la dernière vidéo
J'suis heureux de voir que T'imagines si c'est un programme qui vous plaît aussi
Même s'il est très différent du reste de la chaîne parce que il est pas forcément, comme je l'ai déjà dit, dans un but d'apprentissage pur
Mais plutôt un moment Chill qu'on passe ensemble
Donc ça me fait vachement plaisir
Merci beaucoup
Un gros merci encore une fois aux tippeurs
Pour soutenir le projet
ça me fait vachement plaisir
Vous êtes comme ça !
Merci beaucoup
Love !